One of the things that happens to Joseph is that,
well,
a lot of bad things happened to them because he's the favorite of his father.
His brothers hate him.
And so the first they're going to throw him in a pit.
I think they do throw him in a pit.
Then they sell them to be a slave.
Then he ends up in what we go through the story.
He ends up some places where you probably wouldn't want to go prison being one
of them,
but
it doesn't matter because even when they put him in prison,
he's actually not in prison.
He just figures out how to make the prison work way better.
And then he's in control of the prison.
And it's really,
it's an interesting,
I had this friend,
you know,
and he was very smart,
but very cynical,
and he wasn't employed very well and he got a little older than he should have
given his level of intelligence and employability.
And so he had to take jobs that weren't very intellectually challenging.
You know,
and one of the things I tried to convince him of was that even if he worked,
he wanted to work behind the parts department in an automotive store cause he
liked cars but it was beneath him.
You know,
cause it was sort of a,
as far as he was concerned,
it was a,
he was too smart for a job like that,
which actually turned out not to be true.
He wasn't smart enough for a job like that or he wasn't wise enough.
But you know,
I,
one of the things I tried to tell them was that you're looking at the situation
wrong because even in a simple job so called simple job,
like let's say dishwashing in a restaurant,
which I did an awful lot of,
it's not that simple.
You're dealing with a lot of other people,
very fast staff changeover,
you're feeding people,
you're helping them have a celebration,
you're helping them take a break.
Like you can do it really well and then the kitchen can operate properly and
then people can come out to the restaurant.
It's not a bloody catastrophe.
Like you're,
even when you're doing something that's a menial job,
so to speak,
like dishwashing,
there are ways of doing it really badly,
resentfully and horribly and doing it really well.
And as soon as you do it really well,
it's not a menial job anymore.
It,
it immediately transformed.
No,
I mean,
you can be around people who won't let that happen and you should go get another
job if that's the case.
But if you do it properly,
then it's not meaningful at all.
And that's also a good way out of resentment.
You think,
well,
I've just got this,
you know,
two bit job.
It's like,
yeah,
what if he did it as well as you possibly could?
You know what would happen?
Well,
the first thing that would happen is you'd get a lot smarter,
that's for sure.
And that that's hardly a negative thing.